let's go next to our caller from the 773
area code who's calling from 773 today
my name is Kyle from Florida hey Kyle
what's going on hi I just had a question
about when you think the kind of
demographic shifts and I mean young
people are very focused on on specific
policy issues and those sorts of kind of
demographic changes will start to have a
more significant impact in the midterm
in general election it depends on
getting people more rights honestly
because the demographic shifts are not
happening equally in all states so if
there's a particular one you want to ask
me about maybe I would know about it
maybe I wouldn't but summits I mean the
more interesting ones the most
interesting ones to me are Georgia
Florida and Texas and I don't know in
terms of major national elections
exactly when it is that they'll have a
more defined impact I mean it's sort of
a it's a sliding scale it doesn't all
happen at once but we're already
starting to seeing it with starting to
see it in some districts in Georgia and
Texas for example well and I guess kind
of related to that the they're trying to
actually kneecap the proposition or the
proposition that was on that passed
overwhelmingly to restore the voting
rights of felons who have served their
time in Florida times - yeah yes
attempting to do a poll tax which I mean
does that did have you looked into
whether that's possible but they will be
able to successfully kneecap it
unfortunately it is possible so to
explain to people what Kyle's talking
about in the midterm Florida voted to
restore voting rights to felons who were
no longer on probation or on parole and
after that so that was a referendum a
sort of ballot initiative and then more
recently as we covered on the program
they're looking to only provide or
re-establish those voting rights
when these individuals have paid off
back owed court fees and fines which of
course are extraordinarily oppressive
and regressive to begin with and the
legal argument now is is that a poll tax
is it not I don't honestly they have a
shot at succeeding and I'm gonna let you
go towns extremely loud where you are so
thank you for the call really appreciate
hearing from you